okay
so
that's discriminant analysis when we use
gaussian
densities but now the form that we wrote
down is quite general
and you can use other
estimates of densities and plug them
into this rule
and and get classification rules
so up to now we've been using gaussian
densities with the same
variance for the for the x's in each
class
what if the
variances are different in each class
well you can plug those forms in
and then remember we had that magic
cancellation because of the equal
variances well when the variances are
different in each class
there's no the quadratic terms don't
cancel and so now your discriminant
functions are going to be quadratic
functions of x
okay
so that's one form it's called quadratic
discriminant analysis
another thing you can do
is you
especially this is useful when you have
a large number of features like the 4000
or so that rob mentioned when you really
wouldn't want to estimate
these large
variance covariance matrices
you can assume that in each class the
density factors into a product of
densities
that's that's amounts to saying that the
variables are conditionally independent
in each of the classes
and if you do that and plug it into this
formula over here
you get something known as the naive
bayes classifier
for linear discriminant analysis this
means that the covariances sigma sub k
are diagonal
and
instead of estimating the covariance
matrix
has got if you've got p variables it's
got p squared parameters
but if you assume this diagonal
that it's diagonal you only need to
estimate p parameters again now although
the assumption seems very crude i mean
it's an assumption is wrong
this naive based classifier is actually
very useful in high dimensional problems
and it's one actually where we turn to
later in different forms right
so
in fact we'd probably think it's always
wrong wouldn't we right yeah
and so what happens is you know we end
up with quite
flattened and maybe biased estimates for
the probabilities but in terms of
classification you just need to know
which probability is the largest to
classify so you can tolerate quite a lot
of bias
and and still get good classification
performance
and what you get in return is much
reduced variance from having to estimate
far fewer parameters
and then there's much more other general
forms where we don't assume gaussian at
all we can we can estimate the densities
using our favorite density estimation
technique and then go and plug them back
into this formula and that will give you
a classification rule
it's a very general approach
that can be used and and in fact many of
the classifiers that we we know we can
understand from this point of view
so here we have it quadratic
discriminant analysis uses a different
covariance matrix for each class
and so there's no cancellation of the
sigma so the discriminant functions now
have
the
this distance term
that involves
sigma sub k which is for the kth class
there's a term to do with the the
prior probability and there's a
determinant term that comes from the the
covariance matrix
and you can see
it gives you a curved discriminant
boundary
and and the quadratic terms
matter here because because they they're
different
okay
and so in the left plot here
we see
a case when the true boundary really
should be linear that's the dotted curve
and in this case of course linear
discriminant analysis does a good job
quadratic discriminant analysis curve
somewhat and and gives a slightly bent
boundary but it won't it won't really
affect misclassification performance but
much
in the right-hand plot and now this
other hand
the the true data came from
a situation where the covariances were
different
the the bayes decision boundary is
curved and the quadratic discriminant
analysis pretty much got it whereas
linear discriminant analysis gives you
quite a different boundary in that case
quadratic discriminant analysis is
attractive if the number of variables is
small when the features the number of
variables or features is large you've
got to estimate these big covariance
matrices and things can break down
and and even for lda can break down
years where naive bayes becomes
attractive
it makes a much stronger assumption it
assumes that the covariances in each of
the classes
although different are diagonal
and so that's much fewer parameters
and now when you look at the
discriminant functions
because diagonal and gaussian means that
the
the densities are independent and so
that we have this product here when we
take logs we get a relatively simple
expression
which is in each class it's there's a
contribution of the feature from the the
mean for the class scaled by the
variance there's the determinant term
and there's the prior term
and so this is a
this is the discriminant function for
the kth class for naive bayes and you
compute one of these for each of the
classes the new classifier
you can use mixed features for naive
bayes
and in that case
if what we mean by that is some
qualitative and some quantitative
features
and so for the quantitative ones we'd
use the gaussian and for the qualitative
ones we'd
replace the densities the gaussian
densities by just histograms
or probability mass functions in this
case over the
discrete categories
so naive bayes is very
handy from this point of view
and
and even though it has strong
assumptions it often produces good
classification results
because after once again in
classification we're mainly concerned
about which class has the highest
probability and not whether we got the
probabilities exactly right
okay
so
we've seen two forms of of
classification logistic regression and
linear discriminant analysis and we saw
its generalizations
now it turns out you know are they how
how do they differ
it seems they may be similar
similarities between the two
now it turns out you can show for linear
discriminant analysis
that if you take its
we had expression for the probabilities
for each of the classes so if you have
two class we can show that if you take
the log odds just like we did in
logistic regression
right which is the log of the
probability for class 1 versus the
probability for class two
it's a linear function of x
for two classes
so it's got exactly the same form as
logistic regression
so they both give you linear logistic
models
so the difference is in how the
parameters are estimated
logistic regression uses the conditional
likelihood based on probability of y
given x remember it was using the
probabilities
of a one or zero
given x in each of the classes
and in machine learning this is known as
discriminative learning
using the conditional distribution of y
given x
discriminant analysis
turns out it's estimating these
parameters
over here
using the full likelihood
because it's using the
the distribution of x's and y's
whereas logistic regression was only
using the distribution of y's
and in that case it's known as
generative learning
remember we modeled
the the the means and variances of x in
each of the classes and we model the the
prior probabilities so that can be seen
as modeling the joint distribution of x
and y
so that's one way of seeing what's
different between the two
but despite these differences in
practice the results are often very
similar
and you can use one method with the
other and you're going to get very
similar results
as a footnote
logistic regression can also fit
quadratic boundaries
we use quadratic discriminants analysis
to get quadratic boundaries
but
we can fit quadratic boundaries by
explicitly including quadratic terms in
the model
just like we did in linear regression in
logistic regression we can put in
x squareds and
x i times xjs and terms like that and
just explicitly get a quadratic boundary
okay so
that's the end of this section
that's an introduction to classification
using these two very popular methods and
later on in the class you're going to
see that we're going to come back to
some of these methods and look at more
general versions of them
and and build richer classification
rules and importantly we'll discuss
another very popular method called the
support vector machine which is another
approach to classification and by way of
coming attractions the next section is
going to be on cross validation and
bootstrap
and in that section we will get to meet
uh brad ephron who is our colleague
um and also it was my phd supervisor
many years ago and it was the person who
invented the bootstrap so he'll tell us
a bit about
the bootstrap and how he came about to
how he proposed in his 1980 paper
fantastic